ERIC SCHMIDT: Hi, my
name is Eric Schmidt
I'm a developer advocate in
the Google Cloud platform
team, focused on data
processing and analysis.
In this video, I'm
going to review
core architectural concepts
for performing streaming data
processing.
And then I'll use the
Google Cloud platform,
specifically three manage
services-- Cloud Pub/Sub, Cloud
Dataflow, and
BigQuery-- to implement
several, near
real-time streaming
data processing patterns.
This content is targeted at
programmers, and developers,
and architects interested in
building cloud-based streaming
processing systems.
If you already
have deep knowledge
around modern streaming engines
like Apache Spark, Apache
Storm, or Apache Flink, some of
this content may be redundant.
However, if you're
new to the Cloud,
or have not looked at managed
services on the Google Cloud
platform, this video
should prove useful to you.
This video has
three main sections.
I will first introduce
a sample scenario
to help contextualize
the concepts and business
challenges related to
streaming data processing.
Then, I'll review a collection
of architectural principles
and demonstrate how to use
managed services on the Google
Cloud platform to perform
streaming processing
and analysis.
After watching this
video, you should
have a clear
understanding on how
to implement streaming
data processing workflows
with managed services on
the Google Cloud platform.
This past spring, I
was fortunate to work
with Spotify's engineering
team on their streaming data
processing architecture
while they were migrating
to the Google Cloud platform.
Now, in my spare time,
I'm also a DJ at KXP 90.3
here in Seattle.
And as such, I'm deeply
passionate about music.
The sample for this work was
inspired by my work at KXP
and my work with Spotify.
I encourage you to go read
Spotify's three-part blog
post on their overall data
processing architecture.
You can find the series on the
Spotify Labs blog, or simply
Google Spotify Event
Delivery Architecture.
My sample scenario
is called Testify,
and is based on very
simplified architecture.
And the resulting analysis
is quite narrow, mainly
not to overshadow the main
theme of this video, which
is about understanding
streaming processing.
The sample is based on
fabricated event log data
from a mobile music
application, to which I apply
several fabricated questions.
And these questions
were inspired
by some innovative
work that Spotify
is doing around BigQuery.
Now, to be clear, this sample
is about processing event data,
not about streaming music.
The logical model is as follows.
I have a fake mobile device.
And it emits events
of different meaning
and of different schema.
These events are
pushed to edge servers
hosting applications services.
And these services
emit local event logs.
These logs are then
tailed in real time
and ingested into a queue.
And from there, I will
apply some ETL processing,
and run some transforms to move
that data into a durable store
for further interactive
analysis, dashboarding,
and batch reporting.
The architectural
concepts in this video
can be applied to
nearly any business
challenge across any vertical,
from fraud detection,
to advertising
campaign analysis,
to inventory stock-out alerting,
to real-time leaderboards.
And the same
architectural concepts
apply regardless of
vertical workload.
I picked the music
event processing sample,
because it's fun.
And, well at least for me, it's
something that I really love.
Now, I'd like to review a
collection of terms and tenets
related to data processing.
We will revisit
the testify sample.
But in the meantime,
please keep some
of the top level flow in mind.
Now, throughout this
video, I will deliberately
coalesce the concepts and
physical manifestations
of data processing
and data analysis
into the phrase data processing
to simplify the messaging.
However, they are different.
Data processing is
primarily about movement
and transformation,
AKA ETL-- for example,
extracting log files, and
transforming them, filtering
them, and then loading
them to another location
or durable store.
Data analysis is
primarily about applying
computation or aggregations,
things like count, sum, et
cetera over group collections--
for example, performing
statistical analysis
over all data elements,
or sampled analysis--
for example,
counting the number
of users that
listen to a particular
song by hour or by minute.
Now, in the context
of streaming analysis,
it's also common to join
streams with other streams,
and to join streams with
at rest or batch data.
I make this
distinction upfront, as
the architectural implications
for processing and analysis
are quite different.
However, in practice
they are commonly blended
into the same logical
model, and in some cases
the same physical system.
Now, no matter what
business vertical
you operate in-- finance,
health care, manufacturing,
casual gaming-- or the
discipline in which you work--
accounting, marketing, sales,
customer service-- the number
one blocker for
growth is a concept
I like to call time to answer.
Specifically, how fast
can you get the answer
to a question pertinent to
your business at that time?
In almost all cases,
you're ultimately
dependent upon data processing
and analysis systems
to answer these questions.
Let's say you're an advertising
analyst for a retail company.
The time to answer
a key question like,
what is the conversion rate on
my current marketing campaign,
could mean the difference
between driving ad inventory
to the right customers, or
possibly wasting dollars
on already stocked out products.
If you're in the manufacturing
space focused on production
line efficiency, knowing the
answer to a question like,
what is the current distribution
of to-be-processed processed
orders, and how do those orders
align to my existing machine
setup?
This could be the difference
between positive and negative
margins on your
next production run.
Or a question like, if you're
a casual game developer,
what percentage
of users recently
abandoned my game as a result
of introducing new game logic?
The time to answer here
could have massive impact
on your daily active users.
Or maybe you become the
focus of the next episode
of Silicon Valley.
Now, the theme across
these questions is speed.
I've never met a business
or technical decision
maker that said, I'd really like
to have questions to my answers
with more delay.
The converse is true.
It's the true state of business
today, now more than ever.
Those who can answer
questions faster
are more likely to
succeed and grow.
The challenge is that growth
creates more data, and in turn
creates more questions, thus
more pressure on processing
and analysis systems.
And when implemented
incorrectly,
these underlying systems
increase the time to answer.
Time to answer matters.
Now, for decades businesses have
been using various techniques
for data processing, batch being
one of the most common patterns
to answer questions like the
ones I've previously raised.
While effective, batch
processing on fixed capacity,
non-managed environments present
risks related to cost control,
increased time to answer,
and answer accuracy,
or rather answer inaccuracy.
Let's look at a simple example.
Here, we have a
fixed data set, which
will be processed via
batch job on a fixed
cluster of resources.
When these resources are ready,
and the job schedule time is
hit to start, the job starts.
The job and the
resources are effectively
blocked until the
job is completed.
After the job is completed,
results are admitted.
There is an effective
clock time for this job.
This is, in essence,
the time to answer.
For example, this job took
30 clock minutes to run,
and consumed a total of 200
minutes of resource time.
Now, we're going to
extend the example.
Let's add a new job.
In this case, the new
job will be blocked when
the existing job is running.
The typical response here is
to add more resources, CPU,
memory, disk, and
network capacity,
and deploy the job to these
new specific resources.
Now, one of the challenges
is that you end up
potentially wasting resources.
Notice that the previous
job is now complete.
And the initial
resources are now idle.
Now that the second
job is complete,
our entire collection
of resources is idle.
If you have experience
with Hadoop clusters,
you might be
thinking, well, this
is what the resource
manager and YARN are for?
And, yes, they can be highly
effective at optimizing
resources based on
scheduling semantics.
However, the issue
here is that if there
are no jobs to be scheduled,
the resources will remain idle.
And in some cases, they just
may be better to be torn down.
The other challenge
is that if you
need to increased the
capacity on the cluster,
in an unmanaged
environment you're
going to have to physically
deploy and manage the lifecycle
of those resources.
Let's take a look at the
first job scenario again.
Now, at the time that
the job was scheduled,
the input data is
effectively locked.
In relational
database terms, you
could think about this
as an effective page
lock over the entire data.
However, in this case,
some data arrives late
after the job is started.
And it was really supposed to be
part of the original input set.
Now, the job finishes,
output is created.
But the output is now
only partially correct,
or possibly
completely inaccurate,
depending on the impact
of the late data.
There are many techniques
to deal with this problem.
Now, if the job computation
here is associative,
one could rerun the job
against the new data,
and add the results to
the original job output.
Or one could delete
the original results
and rerun the entire job again.
Each approach has its
own challenges and risks.
To be clear, I'm not saying that
all batch processing is bad,
or that all unmanaged
data processing is bad.
I simply want to point out that
there are inherent challenges
for each approach.
And depending on your
use cases, data volumes,
analysis requirements,
and resource budget,
you may encounter these issues.
The next several concepts
I'm going to talk about
are grafted from two blog
posts, recently written
by an amazing software
engineer, and also
the technical lead for the
MillWheel team here at Google.
His name is Tyler Akidau.
I encourage you to go read them.
Simply Google, streaming
101, and they show up
at the top of the stack
because they're highly relevant
and they're highly popular.
In the previous
unmanaged batch section,
I talked about
late arriving data,
and its impact on the
output of the batch job.
As I start to talk about
streaming processing,
I want to establish a
distinction between the data--
specifically its boundedness--
and the processing approach.
This concept is super
helpful in understanding
the valuable behaviors
of a streaming system,
and how they might be able to
be applied to your processing
problems.
So let's talk about boundedness.
Bounded data is finite.
It's at rest.
It does not change.
For example, you may have 10
terabytes of historical web
log data, specifically
in files, in Avro format,
or JSON, sitting at
rest in a blob store.
Unbounded data is infinite.
It's constantly changing.
It's driven by frequency.
It's driven by changes in size,
and potentially in schema.
And the time associated
with the data in the stream
may be relevant
to the event time,
or to its processing time.
For example, you may be
listening to a TCP socket,
and reading all the
web log data coming
from all of your servers.
Processing, specifically in
this case bounded processing,
think of this as classic
batch processing, specifically
a processing engine
applied to bounded data.
And the same for
unbounded-- this
is a specific mode of processing
applied to an unbound source.
It's important to understand
these definitions,
as their underlying
implementations
create specific
architectural boundaries.
In my previous batch example,
the data was, in fact,
unbounded.
However, the system was
treating it as bounded data.
This is a very
common pattern, where
one would run periodic batch
jobs over unbounded data-- say,
contained in a relational
database like SQL Server,
or a NoSQL store like Mongo.
It's a very valid approach.
But it can lead to
correctness issues,
or make a pattern like session
analysis very challenging.
In addition to boundedness,
the time domain
associated with data
can have a major impact
on how data is processed and the
correctness of the processing
output.
Event time is an explicit time
associated with a data element
or event tied to the
clock time of when
and where the event occurred.
In most cases, the time
is highly distributed,
and potentially volatile.
Processing time is the time
associated with a processing
engine.
In some cases, it
might be the time
the engine ingested the data.
In others, it might
be the time associated
with the step or stage being
executed within the engine.
In most cases, this time is
centralized, or synchronized,
with a common time service.
Let's use an example.
I just played Justin Bieber
on my testify application
at 12:14 GMT on July 25th, 2016.
That was the event time.
However, this event was
processed three minutes later
by my streaming
processing engine.
Now, the distinction between
event time and processing time
here is important,
because it will ultimately
impact the correctness
of my processing output.
For example, if I was trying
to count plays by minute,
my results would be
skewed by three minutes
if I was using processing time.
Now, what I really
wanted to know
is I want to do count
of plays by minute,
were time is relative
to the actual play time,
not processing time.
Now, the minimum delta between
event time and processing time
is relative to the
speed of light,
plus some additional latency,
which we'll talk about next.
Regardless of batch
or streaming modes,
if you're dealing
with unbounded data
and you want to process
data based on event time,
you need to understand
your latency exposure,
and then employ techniques to
deal with late arriving data.
In a perfect world,
latency would be zero.
Well, it would at least be
bounded by the speed of light.
Or it would be nice if
you could understand
and have some type of fixed
overall system latency.
But we don't live
in a perfect world.
In my testify example,
there are three areas
that could create latency.
On the transmission side
from my phone to the cloud,
it could be something as simple
as network unavailability.
Or it could be something
very downstream,
like a slow disk that
is backing a cue.
And those reads are now reduced
on the throughput side, which
would create latency.
In almost all cases,
you don't have control
over these potential issues.
But the best thing you can do is
plan for what level of latency
you could expect,
and that you're
willing to tolerate, and
have a plan with how you
deal with late arriving data.
I'll talk more about how you
deal with late arriving data
in the next section.
Now that we understand
events versus processing time
and the impact of latency, we
need an additional primitive
to rationalize time
into manageable groups.
Having the ability to window
data into finite chunks
enables computation that
would otherwise be impossible.
For example,
without windowing it
would be very
difficult to perform
even a simple aggregation,
like count or sum,
over unbounded data.
In essence, you need
a mechanism to group
all events into
a window in order
to apply an aggregation
to a window that
has some level of
data completeness.
In classic MapReduce,
you'd create
keys that were tied to
start and ends of Windows.
In other system, say
like Apache Storm,
you could set the
time stamp for tuple.
And then that time stamp is
propagated into a window.
Now, not all processing systems
support all window types.
I'll talk a little bit later
about specific windowing
support in different
processing engines.
Before I stop
talking about time,
I need to cover another
important concept that
is tightly bound
to latency, which
is the concept of a watermark.
Here, you can see event
time on the x-axis,
and processing
time on the y-axis.
In a perfect, zero
latency world,
we could use an ideal
watermark that moves linearly
tied to clock time.
But the world is not fair.
And latency is everywhere.
Thus, if we're going to perform
processing based on event time,
we need a heuristic-driven
watermark.
Now, this watermark
is an estimate
based on various
techniques-- for example,
a simple distribution sampler,
or something more sophisticated
like looking at the
oldest unprocessed message
in an upstream queue.
Now, if the heuristic is too
slow, results are delayed.
If the heuristic is too fast,
results may be marked late.
Now, in this example, I'm doing
some fixed window analysis.
Notice that in the event time
window of 12:01 to 12:02,
there is an event of value 9.
But it's been marked as red,
because it was processed way
past the watermark.
It was marked late.
The question is, what do
you do with late data?
I'm going to talk
a little bit more
later about how to
deal with late data,
as well as how to trigger
speculative results
within a window.
We can now tie all
these concepts together,
and end on a crisp
definition of streaming.
Streaming is an execution
engine, system, service,
runner capable of
processing unbounded data.
And when designed correctly,
a streaming processing engine
can provide low latency,
speculative or partial results,
the ability to flexibly
reason about time,
provide controls
for correctness,
and ultimately the power to
perform complex analysis.
Now that I have the basic
terms and tenets laid out
for streaming
processing, I'm going
to use several managed services
on the Google Cloud platform
to build a streaming data
processing application.
Specifically, I'm going to use
Cloud Pub/Sub for ingestion,
Cloud Dataflow for processing
and imperative analysis,
and BigQuery for durable storage
and interactive analysis.
Cloud Pub/Sub is a managed
service for streaming data
on the Google Cloud platform.
Cloud Pub/Sub enables durable,
asynchronous messaging
applications, including patterns
for one to one, one to many,
and many to many.
Cloud Pub/Sub is globally
available with large message
size support, up to
10 megabytes per put.
And Cloud Pub/Sub
club provides at least
once delivery with low
latency and on demand
scalability to one million
messages per second,
and beyond.
Now, Pub/Sub is technically
a streaming engine,
as it can process
unbounded data.
However, it does not provide
mechanisms for reasoning
about time, or the ability
to express computation
over the stream.
We will use other
services to perform
processing and analysis.
As you can see, Pub/Sub is a
hub to enable streams to flow
in and out of GCP services.
Moreover, it can be connected
to any service on the cloud,
or on premise via HTTP, or
directly over sockets via GRPC.
Pub/Sub uses a simple
topic subscription
model to enable fan in and
fan out messaging topologies.
In my testify example,
I may route all events
to a single topic.
Or I could split event
types across topics
and then multiplex them
to multiple subscribers.
Here is a zoomed view of my
testified demo application.
I'm going to show you how
to setup a Cloud Pub/Sub
topic to ingest an unbounded
stream, which will then
be processed by Cloud Dataflow.
In this case, I'll
be using one topic
to ingest a stream
of events being
generated by a data fabricator,
which mimics log creation.
There are several ways to
interact with Cloud Pub/Sub.
You can use the REST API, one
of the Google Cloud client
language libraries, or for
basic management operations
you can use the
Google Cloud console.
You can see that I have two
existing topics in my Google
Cloud console.
I'll create a new topic
called Testify Demo.
Now, once I hit
Create, this topic
is globally available to receive
messages at a default rate
up to 100 megabytes per
second, with a maximum message
size of 10 megabytes.
If you need additional quota,
please follow the instructions
in the quota section of the
Cloud Pub/Sub documentation.
Now, you'll notice that there is
no forced sharding or bucketing
when you setup your topic.
Simply give it a
name, call create,
and then start publishing data.
Now let's look at something a
little bit more interesting.
I previously created a
topic called Testify Events.
This is receiving my
fabricated event data.
This topic has two
active subscriptions.
These were created by
my Cloud Dataflow job
reading the event stream.
Now, let's look at this topic
in my Management Console
called Stackdriver.
Stackdriver is a real-time
monitoring, logging,
and diagnostic service
for Google Cloud, AWS,
and open source packages.
Here, I created a dashboard
for my Pub/Sub resources
showing four graphs-- my
publish rate, my pull rate,
the number of
undelivered messages,
and the oldest
unacknowledged message time.
You can create your
own graphs based
on event rate,
event size, errors,
and many other dimensions.
I built these graphs in order
to monitor the overall lag
in my event processing system.
Now, I'm publishing right now
at approximately 101 to 100,000
events per second.
And I'm reading,
or pulling them,
at roughly the same rates.
And my undelivered
message count is
right around between 150
and 200,000 messages.
Cloud Pub/Sub has a built-in
seven day retention policy
for undelivered messages.
If I were to, say, shut
down my downstream reader--
in this case, Cloud
Dataflow-- all the messages
would be durably
stored for seven days.
Now, one last highlight that
is helpful for Cloud Pub/Sub,
as many other workflows like
complete, storage, et cetera,
is the ability to create
custom alerting policies which
can monitor specific
metrics and thresholds,
and then send you notifications.
Here, I had created a policy
to check a particular metric.
In this case, I wanted to
look at messages published
for my Testify
Events topic, if it
was above a threshold of
50,000 events per second
for greater than one minute.
And in this, case it
would alert the dashboard,
as well as send me an email.
Now that you understand the
basics of Cloud Pub/Sub,
and we've setup a topic, and
showed you some management
techniques.
And we have a live topic
and subscription running.
Let's look at how Cloud Dataflow
is processing the stream.
Google Cloud Dataflow is
a managed data processing
service, and an open
source programming
model that unifies
batch and streaming
processing into one model.
The Cloud Dataflow
service provides
on demand resource deployment,
and management on a per job
basis.
This means you can scale
your data processing
without resource contention and
limits found in fixed clusters.
The service automatically
scales resources up and down
for both batch and
streaming jobs,
freeing you from under or
over-provisioning resources,
and enabling you to optimize
your time to answer.
The Cloud Dataflow
programming model
was the basis for
the now open source
Apache Software
Foundation incubator
project called Apache Beam.
Functionally, Cloud Dataflow
unifies batch and streaming
into one model.
It enables processing in
processing time space,
as well as event time space.
It provides a window [INAUDIBLE]
with support for fixed sliding
and session windows that support
advanced triggering mechanisms
for speculative window
emission, and to deal
with late arriving data.
The Cloud Dataflow
managed service
is geared at driving a no ops,
or no operations deployment
and management model.
Instead of you spending
time downloading packages,
spinning up compute resources,
tuning cluster configuration,
and dealing with
control plane issues,
you simply code your pipeline,
and submit your pipeline
as a job to the service.
And it handles the rest.
You're only charged for the
time that your job executes
on the service.
Since resources are deployed and
managed completely on demand,
you can reduce the capital
cost of deploying and managing
long running fixed
capacity clusters.
The service can
seamlessly transition
between batch and
streaming processing,
providing a single
service to handle
bounded and unbounded
data processing.
Now, with the forthcoming
Apache Beam support,
you'll be able to
migrate your data flow
jobs across Apache Spark,
Apache Flink, and other runners.
Here is a logical view of a
simple Cloud Dataflow pipeline
from my testify workflow.
You submit the
pipeline as a job.
And the service will then
deploy the worker resources
and schedule the work.
In this case, I start
with a bounded source.
I read the log data, apply
some simple transformations,
and then write it
to various shards.
Now, let's migrate this
to an unbounded source,
and turn this into
a streaming process.
Nothing changes
with the pipeline,
other than changing the source.
Finally, let's add
some windowing,
and add a simple aggregator--
in this case a count.
I could continue to add more and
more branches to the pipeline.
I could split the graph.
I could apply varying
windows, and even
apply more sophisticated
aggregations.
This is a view of my running
Cloud Dataflow streaming
job, which is processing
the events published
into my Pub/Sub, and flowing
to related subscriptions.
It has been running for a little
over two hours and 40 minutes.
And it is processed
around 971 million events.
The graph starts by reading
event data from Pub/Sub.
This event data is
text CSV formatted.
You could also process
JSON, Avro XML,
or create your
own custom format.
Of important note-- I'm using
event time as my time domain,
not processing time.
To do this, I tell
Dataflow to look
for a specific label
on each Pub/Sub message
called timestamp.
From there, Dataflow
handles the calculation
of the data watermark, which
as the watermark advances
any window ending before or
at that time will be closed.
I'm using event
time here in order
to provide a higher level of
accuracy for my aggregations.
If I were to use
processing time,
I never could be guaranteed
to have all the data relevant
to a specific event time window.
After reading the
raw stream data,
data is sent to parse transform.
This transform has two steps--
parse and de-serialize.
De-serialize maps the parsed
CSV data into an object
called Event.
From here, the job
has three main goals.
Goal number one is
focused on archiving,
and is mainly a load function
in terms of a typical ETL job.
Specifically, I want to
do some basic formatting
on every event, and
write each event
to a durable store for
additional processing
or analysis.
In this case, my durable
store is BigQuery.
Note-- this data is assigned
to the job's global window,
and does not wait for any
specific window to close.
In essence, it is processed
as fast as possible.
In this case, it's written to
BigQuery via its streaming API.
The latency for this data is
a function of transmit time,
plus Pub/Sub time,
plus data flow time,
plus availability time
in the downstream store.
Well, since I'm not
using windowing,
this latency calculation
may not be very helpful,
if you're trying to
determine data completeness.
More specifically, if you're
trying to perform analysis
over the raw events-- in
this case in BigQuery--
your analysis may be
partially inaccurate
if you're addressing event
times within the latency window.
There are specific
techniques to deal
with late arriving data, as
well as omitting early results,
which I will address next.
Goal number two is to
calculate the total number
of plays per track, per
10-minute fix window.
And I want to update the
output every 15 seconds.
We view this output
like a meter.
As time progresses,
the metric should
increase, as long
as events arrive
for that particular tracking.
Since I have a
fixed window, I can
enforce the duration
for how long
I want to tolerate late data.
And in this case, since I'm
doing some dashboarding,
my threshold is small--
only 15 seconds.
Any late data arriving outside
of the 10-minute window plus 15
seconds will be ignored.
Now, each key--
specifically a track ID--
will have up to 40 updates
updating 15 seconds processing
time over a 10-minute window.
In the testify use case, there
are hundreds of thousands
of tracks.
To deal with this volume
of highly mutating data,
I am using Cloud Bigtable
as the durable store.
The latency for this metric
will be transmit time,
plus Pub/Sub time,
plus 15 seconds,
plus any additional lag
in closing the window,
plus Bigtable write time.
Now, writes the Bigtable
happen in milliseconds,
which greatly reduces
the overall latency
for the metric value.
Goal number three is more of
a data warehousing pattern.
Its purpose is to drive
a rollup aggregation.
I want to calculate the total
number of plays per track,
per 15-minute window.
And in this case, I also want
to address any late arriving
data up to five minutes
after the window closes.
The latency here is transmit
time, plus Pub/Sub time,
plus 15 minutes, plus any
additional lag in closing
the window, plus write time.
Now, there's also
the possibility
that data could arrive
late, up to five
minutes after the widow closes.
And since I'm using
discarding windows,
the new window will only
contain the late arriving data.
For downstream
consumers, they can now
be guaranteed with
high confidence
that this aggregation is a
complete view of the event
stream for that time period.
And if they see
late arriving data,
they can choose
how to handle it.
Now that you have a better
idea of the processing
goals for this pipeline and the
power of data flow's streaming
processing model,
we'll look at what
and how you can perform
additional analysis
over the stream and
its aggregations
using BigQuery and Bigtable.
BigQuery is a fully
managed data warehouse
that provides fast, scalable,
interactive analysis
through familiar SQL syntax.
Queries can address a few
bytes up to petabytes in scale,
and also supports real-time
ingestion of data streams.
BigQuery can ingest up to
100,000 rows per second,
per table.
And you can get
additional throughput
with simple table charting.
This data is
available in seconds,
meaning a query that is
addressing at rest data
can also address data
that was recently ingested
into an unbounded table.
The sources from this
data can come from places
like Pub/Sub, Dataflow.
Now, BigQuery is technically
a streaming engine,
since it can deal
with unbounded data.
However, it does
not have the ability
to rationalize time space.
And specifically, it does not
understand late arriving data,
and does not provide
a triggering mechanism
to handle late data.
This is the role of
an upstream streaming
engine like Cloud Dataflow.
Now, if you have a steady handle
on end to end system latency,
directly bypassing
computation in Dataflow
may be a valid option.
At the same time, if you are
using Dataflow to stream data
into BigQuery it also
makes a lot of sense
to potentially pre-aggregate
data-- for example, performing
group buys and simple
aggregations that can then
be used for common queries.
As you will see in my demo,
using BigQuery is super simple.
You don't have to
worry about indexing,
or re-sharding, or
storage resizing,
or adding server capacity.
You simply load or stream
your data into BigQuery,
and then execute a query.
This is the power of managed
services on the Google Cloud
platform.
This is the BigQuery console
in my Google Cloud project.
I have an existing data set for
my streaming workflow called
Testify.
This dataset contains raw events
streaming from my Dataflow
pipeline, as well as other data,
like track count by window,
and related data, like
artist releases and labels.
Let's take a look
at the event table.
The event table schema is
fairly straightforward.
It has columns like event
ID, event time, user ID,
track ID, and create time.
The table itself
is just a little
over 4.5 terabytes in size.
Now, with this raw
event data, I can
create some very big
and interesting queries,
especially if I join that
raw event data to other data.
Here, I want to calculate the
top artists by stream count.
To do that, I need
to join my raw events
to track information, and track
information to release credit,
in order to resolve
the artist's name.
And then I'll do a group by in
order to get the track count.
Now, it should take
between 20 and 30 seconds
for this query to run.
There you go, 26 and 1/2
seconds processing just
under half a terabyte of data.
And sadly, Justin Bieber is the
top artist by total streams.
Now, the power here
is that I didn't
have to worry about
sharding or indexes.
I simply wrote my
query, and executed it.
And having access to my
real-time information
could be very
valuable, depending
on my data completeness needs.
Now, let's take a
look at the output
from the rollup aggregation
driven by my Dataflow job.
If you recall, this was a
counts of tracks by track ID
by a 15-minute window.
And that transform also
handled late arriving data.
So I'm going to go back and
grab the track ID from Justin
Bieber, and add that as
part of my where clause,
and run this query.
So I'm going to filter Justin
Bieber to see what his track
counts look like over time.
Now, since this is
a roll up, the query
ran much faster,
around 1.7 seconds.
And you can see
that the track count
metric is calculated by
window, that 15-minute window.
And if data arrive
late, the window--
specifically the timing--
would have been marked as late.
You can also see
that the latency
between the end of the
window and the write time
is roughly around 30 seconds.
So the total latency would be
the 15 minutes of the window,
plus the latency
of the write time,
or around 15 minutes
and 30 seconds.
This is highly accurate analysis
against a real-time stream.
Now, this is great.
But let's explore even
lower latency output
from our dashboarding transform.
The output from that transform
is written to Cloud Bigtable.
Cloud Bigtable is Google's
NoSQL big database service.
It's managed and is
designed to handle
massive loads with consistent
low latency and high
throughput.
It's an excellent solution
for highly mutating data
over large key ranges.
Here's my current
testify cluster.
And, as configured,
it can handle
reads and writes at 30,000 QPS
with a consistent latency of 6
milliseconds.
Now, the dashboarding transform
from my Dataflow pipeline emits
accumulating updates every
15 seconds for a given track
and window key.
Let's go back to
the Dataflow console
and look at the
current data watermark
from my Cloud Bigtable I/O step.
So right now, the data
watermark is at 21:41, basically
in the 40th minute
segments in the 2100 hour.
Using my HBase
clients, I'm going
to call a get on tracks
tied to the track
key for Justin Bieber.
And I'm going to look at the
fourth hour and 40th minute
window.
And there's the value right now.
He's had 25,147
streams in that window.
Now, depending where I'm
at in that 15 second cycle,
we should see that
increase, probably
caught a rate on the end there.
There you go.
So now it's at 27,302.
And this will continue to
accumulate all the way up
to the four hour and
50 minute window.
And then we'll cycle a new key.
And the accumulator
will start over.
So this is fantastic.
I have thousands and
thousands of keys.
And I can continue to
mutate them, the values,
over these windows.
Now, the access time
here is a bit inflated.
So it's roughly
about 0.38 seconds,
mainly because I'm querying
from my laptop into the cloud.
If I was doing
this on the cloud,
I'd be seeing response times
at 6, 10-ish millisecond range.
The point here is
that this track count
is dead accurate within 15
seconds of the live stream.
Now, let's pull
this all together.
I built a dashboard
in Data Studio 360.
Google Data Studio
360 turns your data
into beautiful,
informative reports
that are easy to read
and easy to share.
It seamlessly integrates with
BigQuery, Cloud SQL, MySQL,
Google Analytics, AdWords,
and many other data sources.
I chose it because
it's easy to use.
But you could easily apply
these same processing techniques
to drive homegrown
reports, or integrate
the data into maybe some
existing tablo deployments.
Once you have your windowing and
correctness techniques dialed
in, the possibilities are
endless for highly accurate,
low latency streaming data
processing and analysis.
Now, as I start to wrap
up, I want to leave you
with some general guidance.
To start with, ingest
everything into BigQuery.
Now, there are some exceptions.
If you have a very
fast-changing data,
Cloud Bigtable may be
a better fit for you.
Cloud Bigtable is our
managed HBase implementation.
It's good if you're building
a real-time leaderboard
and you need to constantly
update the same keyspace.
Bigtable is a much better fit.
Another thing to consider
is decide if you really need
to do event time processing.
And what cases do you need to
cover that require event time
processing?
Event time processing is more
resource intensive to use.
So use it wisely.
I strongly suggest that you
use Google Cloud Dataflow
to produce aggregations
that are going
to be commonly used for
queries in another system,
like BigQuery.
This will ultimately reduce
the time and resource
cost related to those queries.
Here's some general guidance
for Dataflow as you get started.
Now, the first one
challenges everything
that I said about streaming.
Keep in mind that
streaming isn't a solution
to all problems.
For example, performing a bulk
database snapshot migration
is much better suited
for a batch job.
And, specifically, you
could run that batch job
with Cloud Dataflow.
Now, the main decision point
about using batch or streaming
will be around the
boundedness, and your ability
to deal with latency
and data correctness.
In either case of
batch or streaming,
utilize auto scaling to remove
the guesswork from resource
capacity planning.
If you are going to use windows,
specifically session windows,
use them carefully.
They are very powerful.
But they're also very
resource intensive.
In a lot of cases, you
may be able to use fixed
windows over session windows.
This next one may be obvious.
But the guidance
says to prune output
from your transforms
inside of your pipeline
as much as possible.
This helps reduce network
transmission and serialization
overhead.
If you are using Dataflow in
streaming mode with Pub/Sub,
I encourage you to use
additional subscriptions
in order to do backfill
or emergency replay.
And, finally, I encourage
you to use custom
transforms as much as possible.
This will help
with composability,
as you build more
and new pipelines.
For BigQuery, I have
the following guidance.
I already said this,
but I'll say it again.
Ingest everything into BigQuery.
It's cost effective,
especially when
addressing historical data.
At a penny per gig, it is
an excellent alternative
to standard blob storage.
Plus, you have access to it via
a query, or via Cloud Dataflow.
Next guidance is, select only
the columns that you need.
Again, sounds obvious,
but I've seen query
after query that
wastefully addresses
data that is never used.
Next, consider restricting
access to raw event tables,
especially if you're
following this guidance
around streaming and streaming
everything into BigQuery.
And you restrict
access to a few folks
whose job it is to write queries
to answer business questions.
Now, unfettered access
to all data is great.
But it comes with some
risks, both security concerns
as well as cost control.
Fortunately, BigQuery
has a very flexible model
to control table access.
And, finally, if you need
more processing power,
simply request more slots.
We're here to serve.
Streaming data processing,
when implemented correctly,
can reduce the time
to answer and increase
accuracy of analysis.
Event time processing is a
critical architectural need
when attempting to
rationalize data completeness.
Now, some streaming engines
are more robust than others.
And this is a good thing.
It all comes down to the
ability to couple these systems
together, and make sure that
they work better together.
Managed services
remove the element
of human interaction
and human costs,
specifically deploying and
babysitting infrastructure.
Data processing analysis is
about writing amazing pipelines
and queries to solve
business problems,
not deploying and
managing servers.
Now, I only touched on Cloud
Pub/Sub, Cloud Dataflow,
and BigQuery really
to drill home
the point about the power of
managed services and streaming
engine composability.
But there is so much additional
power on the Google Cloud
platform for data processing.
If you want to bring your
existing Hadoop workloads
to the Cloud, great, we
have amazing managed support
for Hadoop via Cloud Dataproc.
If you want ultra low latency,
high throughput, durable
storage for changing
key data, Cloud Bigtable
is an excellent
managed alternative
to standalone HBase.
If you want highly
available, globally
addressable NoSQL Datastore
is an excellent solution.
If you want managed
MySQL, try out Cloud SQL.
Now, beyond being a platform
leader for streaming
processing, the
Google Cloud platform
is an amazing place for any
scale of data processing
and analysis.
I will leave you with
the simplest of advice.
If you have not
already, I encourage
you to go and read the docs
for Cloud Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
and BigQuery.
Understand the value and
feature set of each product.
Then, specifically, go
get out the Cloud Dataflow
mobile gaming example.
It's a solid implementation
of a feature set, grounded
in real world use cases.
Then write your own pipeline.
But keep it simple.
Answer one question, end to
end, and then build from there.
Finally, have fun.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]